نعم الصوره هنا في هذه المدينه تنقسم الى
جزئين الجزء الذي نحن فيه وهي عمليات
الاغاثه والمساعده نحن في الحديقه للجامعه
التي تحولت الى مركز لايواء الذين ياتون
من كل المناطق والذين ايضا خرجوا من
الاحياء القريبه في هذه المدينه هنالك
المئات من المخيمات فقط هذا المبنى المؤلف
من
طبقين يصح ان يبات به ونحن يعني بيتنا في
هذا امامنا لان الارتدادات من هزات اخر
ارتدادات حصلت في الساعه العاشره ليلا وهز
هذا المبنى بالاتجاه بالاتجاهين وايضا بكل
البحات الخارجيه هنالك المئات من المخيمات
التي نصبت على اعجل هنا ايضا نشاهد الفرق
من المتطوعين من الشباب الذين هم بحسب
اختصاصات متنوعه منهم من ياتي
ويعمل على فرز هذه المواد التي التي لم
تنفك ان تاتي الى المدينه منذ الامس ومنهم
من هو متخصص بعمليات رفع الانقاد يبدو
ويظهر ان هذه المنطقه وهذا المخيم هو
انطلاق للعمليات ان كان لرفع الالقاء داخل
المدينه او ان كان ايضا لتقديم المساعدات
من البسه واطعمه ومواد غذائيه وحتى حرامات
وحتى
وسادات وبطانيات الهم الاكبر الذي يحتاجه
المواطن التركي منذ ثلاثه ايام الى هذا
اليوم هو ان يجد مكانا اقله
بامنا للمبيت به وهذا ما تعمل عليه
الحكومه وتعمل عليه ايضا الجمعيات
الانسانيه بمختلف تشعباتها والوانها وايضا
الشبابيه منها هذه المدينه قمنا بجولات
امشن على الاقدام لان ليس هنالك من وسيله
نقل نشهد للحصول على وسيله للانتقال الى
الملاكم الداخليه استطيع كل الابنيه هي
متصدعه وغير صالحه للسكن اطلاقا حتى هذا
البناء من الداخل تجد الى انه متصدع
ومتشقق وتتخوف ولكن ما دام انهم من
الطابقين طبقتين يعني ليس هنالك من خوف
مثل الطبقات العاشره او الحاديه عشر كما
في الخلف ايضا يوجد في المقلب الاخر مكان
خصص لتقديم الطعام الفطور والغداء والعشاء
وهو على مدار الساعه يعمل بالامس كان عده
لايفات مباشره من تلك المنطقه من تلك
المحله الجهود على مختلف انواعها هي
متعدده ومتنوعه الجيش التركي يزج بحاملات
من
الحمينات العسكريه التي كانت تنقل
الجرافات وتنقل الالات الثقيله التي تعمل
على رفع الانقاض بالاضافه ايضا الى الاطقم
المتدربه والمتخصصه